National Rifle Association executive
vice president and CEO Wayne LaPierre
Wayne good to see you again sir how are
you
good evening shot up but we're in shock
and morning probably like everyone else
out there it's an unimaginable tragedy a
lot of our members were out there we
have friends that had family there that
were wounded and we've just been praying
and like everybody else in the country
for this unimaginable tragedy that being
stolen I mean the other side is the
other side on the other hand has been so
outright trying to politicize this
tragedy that we did feel the need to
speak out today on this whole bump stock
issue you know I for years have tried to
correct the media on semi-automatics
when they said they were fully automatic
firearms when they died in Feinstein and
Schumer and all the rest of them said
they were machine guns for years I'd set
the record straight and then the Obama
administration a couple years ago
approves this device called a bump stack
well if you take a look at it I mean any
look at it it takes a semi-automatic
firearm and it makes it perform like a
fully automatic firearm it makes it
function like one and what the NRA has
said is we ought to take a look at that
see if it's in compliance with federal
law and it's worthy of additional
regulation that being said we didn't say
ban we didn't say confiscate when in a
lot of ways people like Bret Stevens and
Michael Moore and Nancy Pelosi they're
just revealing what their true
intentions have always been and that is
they really don't want the average
citizen they don't believe in the
Constitution they don't believe in the
right of law-abiding citizens to keep
and bear arms and I just pointed out the
great hypocrisy most of these people
they have security guards they have
their fortresses at their house they
have people at the self-congratulatory
events like the Oscars and Emmys the
average American has one usually they
have themselves to rely on great
hypocrisy or no
yeah one thing the American public
always knows is the elites always
protect themself and they always protect
themselves with guns and then they
lecture the American public how you
shouldn't do that but in the heart of
the American public all over this
country they see these monsters and they
don't want to be alone out there they
want to be able to protect themselves
one of the things that happened in Las
Vegas when they said shelter-in-place
the first thing that came up when they
were sheltered they said to somebody
have a gun we saw it with a hurricane's
this past week in Texas in Florida and
places like that Louisiana people learn
that when the waters rising when it goes
dark the American public values this
freedom to protect themselves and now
you have Dianne Feinstein and Schumer in
the media to get this horrible tragedy
and they want to piggyback their whole
agenda the banned guns restrict
law-abiding people for the last 20 years
this circus on the back of this tragedy
and enacted and what the NRA is final
for is reciprocity enforce the existing
federal gun laws protect the Americans
right to protect themselves you know
Wayne when you crunch the numbers and
you look at Chicago and the homicide
rate which we've talked an awful lot I
we've even actually one night scrolled
the names of all the people nobody was
paying attention this is Obama's you
know adopted hometown you know it's like
one Vegas Massacre a month thirty nine
hundred people killed in Chicago while
Obama's president eighteen thousand shot
shootings in just the last six years of
his presidency where were these liberal
voices then I didn't hear a word out of
them but they that's right these
monsters that were doing that in Chicago
they don't care about the law what
you've got to do is you've got to go in
and take them off the street and put
them in prisons I mean if legislation
work Boston Massacre wouldn't have
happened San Bernardino where California
has every gun law you can imagine on the
books that wouldn't have happened in
Paris where they have complete gun bans
that wouldn't have happened Brussels all
over the world where the people are
dissing
these monsters these bad guys go about
their business they could care less what
laws are on the books and that good
people want to protect themself they
want to defend themselves that's why
we're fighting for reciprocity and they
want to preserve this freedom that they
know the elite protect for themselves
and yet would take away from the honest
people and the average people and by
gosh the NRA is not where did that
happen
the NRA gets a bad rap and I'm a proud
member but it's just the fact how many
people a year do you teach gun security
and safety - how many people a year have
protected their the lives of loved ones
because they had the ability to defend
themselves with a weapon well that's
exactly right Sean I mean we teach
millions of people we spend millions of
dollars every year teaching people
safety and responsibility and this
Hollywood crowd makes billions of years
every single day teaching gun
irresponsibility in the American public
the apocrypha is beyond belief
they criticize me for saying people
ought to be able to protect themselves
from murderers rapists and robbers and
then they make billions depicting every
night what I'm without those same
situations the apocrypha coming out of
Hollywood is beyond belief the American
public doesn't buy into it and the
American public want to protect them
wants to be able to protect themselves
from these elitist that protect
themselves with the very firearms they
would ban for the average citizen and I
urge people if they want to learn safety
and security of firearms the NRA does
help a lot of people Wayne thank you for
being with us we appreciate it